[Music]
i ruled
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
kos
and today i bring you probably
the best villain from spider-man's role
gallery
well my best villain from spider-man's
rogue gallery
um today i bring you xm
studios electro
now i know you guys are saying uh
spiderman's
uh best villain he i'm talking about my
best village
i'm talking about a character uh that
when i grew up
you know when i was younger i i swear
if in the beginnings if if you asked me
to have a superpower
it was going to be the power over
electricity and it was going to be that
power to
to shock them you know because the
shocker
used vibration powers so electro
actually used electricity and when i had
first saw the statue i was like it was
utter
amazement to me uh in in the level of
details and stuff
that's on the statue the anatomy and
everything
but let's back it up let's back it up
all right so
uh on last episode of iop
i had hip hop game on shout out to my
boy hip hop gamer
uh and i was
telling him the story that i'm going to
tell for electro
when um you know how i almost
you know tried to become electro when i
was younger
and he told me when he was younger
because he has a slight scar
on the side of his mouth that when he
was younger he bit electrical cord
accord it was electrical cord and he got
shot
i had such a similar experience i was
playing on the trains
uh you know you growing up in the late
80s early 90s
you know you run the trains and we're
running on the trains and we get into
empty train car
and i'm there my friends we're doing
flips on the banisters and stuff like
that and we're joking around
so they would have little murals up
at the top so one of the little murals
was down and i saw a light bulb
i reached in to touch the light bulb not
knowing that there was an exposed wire
got electrocuted so hard that i thought
somebody pushed me in my back i fell
down got up lucky to be alive today
uh but that's you know wild stuff in
your youth i could have been
a headline in the newspaper full you
know uh but
i wasn't and thankfully so so
i proceeded to read comic books with a
different
vigor when it came to electro because
the level of currency that was flowing
through my body that at that moment
i didn't know what spider-man was going
through when he fought electro and why
he had to change the suit
and get insulated boots and insulated
gloves and use insulated webbing
and all the stuff i was so naive at a
young age when it came to
electricity and how dangerous it
actually was
well electro is probably the most
dangerous
uh villain that spider-man had i will
watch him on saturday morning cartoons
and uh during the week too they they
would have them in the morning
on spider-man then i think he came on
spiderman with his amazing friends
probably an episode
or so with electro there and electro
was always the highlight now there's a
two is two portraits
it's this portrait right here that they
have like from the ultimates and i will
give it
uh in close picture because somebody
asked for pictures so i'm gonna do a
little bit of pictures
so y'all can see that in close picture
of it but i'm going to go with the
classic
uh electrocuted uh spiked
uh mask that i love that you see right
here i believe daniel belted this statue
um there's real cable copper
a wiring here um
the housing is fantastic so he must be
inside some industrial area that
conducts electricity
uh see because electrical is one giant
battery
and he's able to store the energy in and
then dissipate the energy
uh early on they used to have wiring in
his costume and i think the mob paid for
him to get enhancements and all this
other stuff
and this in his story has been retconned
so much i got to give a shout out to
jamie foxx
because uh you know for a long time
elektro
is a a white character and jamie foxx
actually did him in the ultimate
universe
uh the electro looks like he's
a black character he's not he's still a
white character
but i thought that you know uh race
transcended the character because
jamie foxx gave a actual uh great
depiction
uh i believe his name is max dillion uh
of max and gave a great depiction of
electro
for me that amazing spider-man it was
it was fantastic i i thought it was a
great job on a character that i
love and that's the story that i got
besides
my my youthful story but this character
changed the way that i looked at
the the the rogue squadron of spider-man
you know like
his rope the rope gallery the rope
squadron think about the video game
the rogue gallery is spider-man um i
really look at it
differently you know he's part of the
sinister six and
he's never truly had his one epic story
like craven's last hunt you know um
something that you can really sink your
teeth in
and i hope marvel and disney uh actually
get together
with sony and and gives this character
that
actual deep uh story
that that is that is needed because i
think his powers is underrated
but let's get into the statue let's get
into
everything this statue is about
the real wiring excuse me
the real wiring really sets this statue
apart from other statues
you you have that uh the the belt the
costume
the colors everything is
textured down to the outline
like he's in a comic book with the dark
shaded
outlines of the character you have the
blacks
inside each black there's like a
rubber lining like he's insulated like
the suit is
insulated the electro boats here coming
all the way down to the stitching on the
outside
this statue is under rated
completely underrated and i think it's a
top-notch statue
especially when it comes to spider-man
this statue is a must-have especially if
you capturing
all the sinister six and having your
spider-man being shown
he was definitely one of the ones i
needed the most
and then i will go into the rest of
spider-man's role gallery
but i had to start it off with my boy
from the sinister six
xm studios electro well this is a part
in the video
when i'm going to ask you to like follow
and subscribe
and hit that join button hit that joy
button
you heard that little hiccup right there
hit the enjoy button it's down at the
bottom
and also go to lawsofgaming.net where
you can see
all the uh episodes of kos last word
with lord cognito and ibontis
and also go to see
[Music]
old episodes of iron lords podcast
today's a tongue twister day and i'm
gonna leave that in there
so you guys can have a joke or two about
it later on
but i'm telling you we have
huge stuff coming new merch coming
and i have more statues that are going
to be shown
especially in the vein of spider-man's
role gallery i have a huge
xm studio spider-man collection and i
can't wait to show it to you guys
stick around look at the statue in all
its glory
listen to some dope music and next week
i might give you something a little bit
scary
and in a lab coat stay
[Music]
collected
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
wow
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
i rule
[Music]
you